Logan is arguably the best X-Men movie yet,
liberally borrowing elements from the popular
Old Man Logan comics arc.
That story was packed with references from
the Marvel Universe, and since Fox doesn't
have the rights to most of those characters,
it might seem safe to assume Logan doesn't
have many Easter eggs of its own.
But you'd be wrong, bub.
Here's a spoiler-filled look at some Logan
Easter eggs you totally missed.
X-Men #132
One of Logan's key plot points comes from
the old issues of X-Men comics that Laura
carries around with her, which supposedly
contain the coordinates for the secret mutant
haven Eden.
One of these issues is #132.
While the comic they show is a prop made for
the film, the decision to use #132 as the
issue number isn't random at all.
In the real world, X-Men #132 marks the first
appearance of the cyborg Donald Pierce — one
of the film's main bad guys, who battled Wolverine
in that very issue.
So meta!
Fat Albert
The evil Wolverine clone X-24 isn't in the
comics, but he seems to be based on a real
character with the slightly less scary name
of Albert.
Albert was a robotic version of Wolverine
built by Donald Pierce as part of a weird
plan to kill Wolverine using an android bomb
disguised as a little girl.
It didn't work, but at least Albert acquitted
himself a little better in the movies.
Rictor, Rebecca, Charlotte, Bobby, Delilah
Just as Laura was created using Wolverine's
DNA, so too were her friends apparently created
using the DNA of other mutants.
One of the kids, for instance, has Iceman's
freezing power, while another has Pyro's fire
power.
Logan also finds in the case files a reference
to Christopher Bradley, who appeared in X-Men
Origins: Wolverine as part of Team X.
He was the mutant who could control electricity,
just like the kid who electrifies the Jeep
at the end.
And finally, the leader of the kids, Rictor,
is a member of X-Force in the comics.
Alkali Transigen
The evil corporation breeding mutant slaves,
Alkali Transigen, got its really awkward name
from the comics: the secret facility where
Wolverine had the adamantium bonded to his
bones by William Stryker was actually located
at Alkali Lake, which was seen in several
previous X-Men movies.
The Reavers
Alkali Transigen isn't just making mutant
slaves, they're also really busy enhancing
their private army of human soldiers with
mechanical arms, legs, and other cybernetic
doodads.
At one point in the movie, this gang of cyborg
mercenaries is referred to as the Reavers,
which is fitting, because in the comics, the
Reavers are an army of cyborgs financed and
commanded by — that's right — Donald Pierce.
Knick-knacks
Considering how eagerly Logan seems to want
to forget his past, he carries an awful lot
of mementos.
Not only is he toting around Chekov's adamantium
bullet, he also has a samurai sword on the
wall of his shack as a nod to his time spent
in Japan.
And he apparently bought his dog tags in bulk
at some point, because he seems to have an
endless supply of the things just to stare
at.
It just wouldn't be a Wolverine movie without
him staring at those dog tags.
Greenwood Cemetery
At the beginning of the film, Logan is making
ends meet as a limo driver.
He ends up bringing some random people to
a cemetery, where he has his first encounter
with Laura.
But that's not just any burial ground: Greenwood
Cemetery has appeared in Marvel Comics for
years, in titles ranging from Fantastic Four
to The New Warriors.
Patrick Stewart's childhood memories
During a key bonding scene in which Professor
X and Laura watch the classic 1953 western
Shane, Xavier tells her he saw the movie in
the Essoldo Cinema when he was just a little
kid himself.
That may have actually been a true story,
because Essoldo was a chain of theaters that
operated in Northern England during the 1940s
and 1950s when Patrick Stewart was growing
up.
"Fascinating, absolutely fascinating!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!